He was, for most of the last 40 years of his life,...
...the most recognizable human being on the planet.
And even when Parkinson's Disease slowed his step and his speech,...
...he still reveled in that recognition.
He loved people the way no other athlete in his time...
...and few public figures loved people.
He loved to sign autographs.
He loved to pose for pictures with the famous and the unknown.
He loved to perform his simple magic tricks for audiences small or large.
He loved being Muhammad Ali.
Ali spent most of his final years travelling as much as any human alive,...
...most often for charities, preaching and practicing love.
Still the most charismatic of all athletes, still lighting up every room he graced.
Still, undisputedly, the Greatest.